-Chloe Bailey,
you look gorgeous.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
You've been on my show
a bunch of times performing.
-Yeah.
-But now I finally
get a chance to talk to you.
-I'm so happy to do this.
You always have, like,
the best energy
and make me feel
so warm inside,
so I'm happy we get
to do this again.
Thank you.
-Oh, good. I'm loving this.
Alright, perfect.
First of all, "That's My Jam."
You crushed it.
-Thank you.
-Wait till you see Chloe Bailey.
You crushed it on the show.
-Thank you so much.
I had the best time.
-Did you have fun?
-Yes. Halle and I,
we were so excited.
And I think what made it
more exciting
is how we were
on separate teams,
how you guys split us up.
-Did you think you were going
to be on the same team?
-Yes, and if we were
on the same team,
I think we would have won.
-Yeah.
-We would have beat out
anybody's butt.
-No, yeah, because you were --
[ Applause ]
-But you are,
you're a professional.
I mean,
you're professional singers.
You can really sing.
-Thanks.
-Yeah, I mean...
-Sometimes.
-There's a mix
that we do on the show
that is so good
of breakup songs,
but you guys got
to wait to see that.
It's really, really good.
-Oh, I can't wait.
-Is it tough competing
against your sister?
-With competitive
games like that?
No, because I'm so competitive
and I love to win,
and she loves to win as well,
so it just makes it
more exciting.
-I wanted to show a clip,
just because
you made your sister
kind of get sprayed
just because you were
such a good singer.
Look at you laughing.
It made you that happy
to spray your sister?
-No, because we were
so nervous about our hair
and makeup, we were like,
"Ahh, no."
-And it happened to her?
-Yeah.
-Here's a taste of
next Monday's episode of
"That's My Jam," take a look.
-♪ I don't want no scrub ♪
♪ A scrub is a guy
that can't get no love from me ♪
♪ Hangin out the passenger side
of his best friend's ride ♪
♪ Trying to holler at me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Screams ]
-It keeps going!
-I'm so sorry.
Yeah,
I knew as soon as you started.
I knew when it started,
I'm like, "Oh."
-Oh, man, that was so fun.
That was so fun.
-Was there a moment
that you realized
that you knew
you wanted to be a singer?
-When I was 2 or 3, my aunt,
she always tells
the story how I was singing
"Fallin'" by Alicia Keys
in my car seat.
And she goes to my parents
and she's like,
"Did you know she can sing?"
So I feel like I've been doing
music ever since I could talk.
-Wow.
-That was the jam, Alicia Keys.
Who else influenced you?
-Beyonce, Missy Elliott,
Alicia Keys.
And the crazy thing is,
that was the first concert
I went to in Atlanta, and I had
my little Dangerously in Love
binoculars from
the nosebleed seats.
And I was looking down
and five-year-old Chloe
was like, "You know what?
I'm gonna do that one day."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-That's when I knew.
-Yeah, I love that
you just knew that right there.
And weirdly, you ended up --
well, you worked
with Beyonce, right?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-On a movie.
-Isn't that crazy?
"Fighting Temptations."
-"The Fighting Temptations."
I love that movie.
Here's a picture of
you and Beyonce,
you as a --
[ Crowd awws ]
How was that experience?
-I remember this exact moment.
One, I just was in love
with my outfit
and my little flip-flop wedges.
And when I saw that we were
in the same color,
I got really excited
and I was like,
"Can I take a picture, please?"
And she was so nice to me.
And even at the wrap party,
she'd hold me
and we danced the night away.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
-She is really, unbelievably...
-She's...
-She should be where she is.
-Yeah.
-'Cause she's so nice
to everybody.
-She's incredibly amazing.
And even at the premiere,
it was really funny.
Halle and I, we were crawling
under people's legs
just to get to her.
And sis's hair
got caught in her dress.
She had, like, a sequins dress.
Isn't that funny?
-She got her hair caught
and Beyonce's dress?
-Mm-hmm.
-Was she cool with it?
-Yeah, she was fine with it.
She was so graceful.
And Halle and I were excited,
and I feel like
that was the moment
my love really began for her,
because she was so kind
to little Chloe.
-Well, fast forward 20 years,
little Chloe.
Now you are amazing,
and you're signed
to Beyonce's record label,
and you just released
your debut solo album.
Yes.
-Chloe, it's called "In Pieces."
-Yes, it is.
-And you designed this album
cover yourself, by the way.
I actually like
this part right here.
-Yeah.
I saw this photo
of a porcelain doll,
and she was holding, like,
a bloodied heart and like,
she ripped it out of her chest,
and she was like,
in kind of like
a Victorian outfit like this.
-Yeah.
-And I was so inspired.
And just off of that photo,
I created the song
that's on the album now,
"Heart on My Sleeve,"
like three years ago,
because I wanted to be
so open and vulnerable
about my feelings
and my emotions
and how loving and giving
and naive I could be at times,
and it would stab me in the back
and the butt every time.
So I was like, you know what?
I'm going to make an album
all about heartbreak
and feeling like
you're not good enough.
And even though you might
seem perfect on the outside,
like the porcelain doll,
when you come extra close,
you'll see all the little cracks
from breaking
and gluing yourself
back together again.
Yeah, so that's why I called it
"In Pieces," for sure.
-I love that.
-Oh, my gosh.
That's fantastic.
Congratulations. Well done.
It's a great record.
-Thank you so much.
That means a lot,
coming from you.
-And also, I want to
tell about your movie,
"Praise This."
-Yes.
It's on streaming,
on Peacock as of today.
It's brand new.
Can you tell everyone
what the movie is about?
-Yes, so Praise This,"
I play a girl named Sam.
She's a struggling musician
and she's willing to do
whatever to get her career
off the ground,
like, she gets herself
into some trouble.
And she's quite a B-word.
But she goes with
her family in Atlanta
and she somehow
gets mixed up with
the gospel praise team crowd.
-Yeah. Do you like
playing this character?
-I do. Because you know why?
-Can I guess why?
-Yeah.
-Because I think
you're so not a B-word,
so when you get to play one,
it's like, "Let's go."
-"Let's go."
-Am I right?
-No, it was amazing,
because all of my pent-up
emotion and like,
comebacks that I wanted
to say back to people
that I thought
about the next day
but never had the chance to say,
I got to say it as Sam.
-Yeah, you got to say it as Sam.
-Let's go!
-And you get to sing.
-And I got to sing.
-You get to sing. You can act.
You got it all, pal.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Chloe Bailey
in "Praise This." Take a look.
-♪ I know the Lord
can see my potential ♪
♪ I've been working ♪
♪ I told him it's been
up since I met you ♪
♪ Pull the curtain ♪
♪ You always
give the word I'm deserving ♪
♪ That's for certain ♪
♪ I was tired of being
tired of being tired, yeah ♪
♪ You walk with me every day ♪
♪ And you help me in every way ♪
♪ I'll meet you at
Heaven's Gate ♪
♪ But for now, I'mma levitate ♪
♪ I lived by the bottle, 'cause
that's the way that I met ♪
♪ You know that I'm learning ♪
♪ You said it's okay
at any rate ♪
♪ Sometimes I get down ♪
♪ I get down,
and you know that ♪
♪ I keep my hands up to God,
all I need right now ♪
♪ I need you, God ♪
-Yeah, Chloe Bailey! Come on!
Chloe, "In Pieces" is out.
"Praise This" is streaming
now on Peacock.
Catch her April 17th
at 10 p.m. on "That's My Jam."
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around.